Trascrizione: Martina Abrami
Revisore: Veronica Viscardi
Buonasera a tutti.
Mi presento, io sono Giulia
e sono un’insegnante
di comportamento e buone maniere.
E sono qui per condurre
un seminario intensivo,
ma che dico intensivo, molto intensivo,
oserei dire un seminario lampo
dal titolo,
forse potete intuire...
Siete timidi? Forza!
Molto bene, c’è scritto!
Non era difficile.
(Ride)
“Si può far!”, ma la domanda
che sorge spontanea è,
e la sento proprio che friccica sotto
si può fare cosa?
Si può diventare la moglie perfetta,
quella che ogni uomo
vorrebbe al suo fianco.
Sento un po’ di scetticismo
nel pubblico, eh?
Per alzata di mano quanti pensano
che non possa esistere la moglie perfetta.
Ecco un bel due in pagella a tutti quanti.
Perché io sono qui
per dimostrarvi scientificamente
che seguendo alcune piccole
e semplici regole
tutte le donne possono aspirare
a diventare le mogli perfette.
Quelli che hanno alzato le mani prima
non erano con la moglie mi pare di capire.
Grazie a questo corso intensivo
imparerete a truccarvi
valorizzando il vostro viso,
a stirare facendo gli squat,
ma soprattutto a mentire a vostro marito
per farlo sentire più uomo.
Dunque partiamo subito!
Bando alle ciance
con la regola numero uno.
Ah sii bella eh?
Inutile dirlo signore, la bellezza conta.
La storia della bellezza interiore
è stata inventata dai?
Brutti!
(Ride)
Quindi, in casi estremi,
io consiglio la chirurgia plastica.
E partite subito, eh.
20-25 anni al massimo perché si sa
che dopo è tutto una parabola discendente.
Signora mia, un decadimento,
disfacimento, un ammollamento,
una tragedia che non vi sto qui a dire.
Si affloscia tutto e quando dico tutto,
ho detto tutto...
(Ride)
E quindi correte ai ripari
il prima possibile.
Ma se invece partite da una buona base,
vi basterà avere delle piccole accortezze
per accogliere il vostro uomo.
Riposati cinque minuti
prima del suo arrivo
perché ti trovi fresca e sorridente,
lavati i denti, metti lo smalto,
ceretta impeccabile,
mascara come se piovesse,
cosa saremmo, signore, senza il mascara?
E soprattutto mettete un vestito
che sia una perfetta via di mezzo
tra Santa Maria Goretti e una pornodiva.
Se a causa di un infarto del miocardio,
un ictus cerebrale
non avete potuto portare
a compimento queste semplici cose...
male, avreste dovuto
organizzarvi per tempo,
io vi consiglio di optare
per il Santo Graal dei salva tempo:
un push-up!
Avrà qualcosa da guardare
e vi assicuro non si renderà
conto di nulla intorno a lui.
(Ride)
Regola numero due: la cucina, signore!
Regno indiscusso del nostro sesso.
Fargli trovare un piatto caldo
quando rientra dal lavoro
è tra i compiti fondamentali
della perfetta moglie.
Evita di tardare,
non vuoi che dopo
una dura giornata di lavoro
lui debba spendere altre energie
per arrabbiarsi con te
o addirittura picchiarti.
Anche perché si sa, il sangue macchia,
non viene via manco a pagarlo oro.
Si attacca le piastrelle
e più lo pulisci, più vien fuori!
Una tragedia, è tremendo.
(Ride)
E se davvero ci tenete a lui...
questa bella coppia giovane,
io lo so che ci tenete!
È bene che impariate a fare
i suoi piatti preferiti.
Li sai fare i suoi piatti preferiti?
Perché ti spiego un segreto.
È possibile farli
come li faceva sua mamma.
Serve solo duro lavoro e dedizione.
Regola numero tre:
sii dolce e comprensiva,
calda, disponibile, aperta,
sensibile, paziente,
materna ma seducente,
provocante ma non provocatoria,
intelligente ma non saccente,
aderente, avvolgente,
irriverente, deferente,
ammorbidente, detergente,
badante, demente,
deficiente, cretina, stupida.
Chi più ne ha, più ne metta!
(Ride)
E tutte queste cose insieme, sì signora.
Tu ridi, eh.
C’è poco da ridere.
(Ride)
Passiamo a, come cosa fondamentale,
signora, signore,
ridete, spesso ma non troppo
perché non siete delle prostitute
e soprattutto cercate
il tipo di risata giusta
per lui in quel momento.
Se, per esempio, volete ridere
alle sue battute
optate per una risata entusiasta.
(Risata entusiasta)
Bella questa!
Se volete fargli capire
che siete dalla sua parte
e lo comprendete profondamente,
optate per una risata empatica.
(Risata empatica)
Eh...
Se lo volete far sentire più uomo,
optate per una risata virilizzante.
(Risata virilizzante)
Ma chi sei? Ma che... ma che è...
Ma veramente una roba incredibile!
(Risata virilizzante)
Se volete ricordargli che siete lì
e lo state ascoltando,
optate per una risata di presenza,
breve e con dei piccoli intercalari
come, ad esempio:
(Risata di presenza)
E certo! Eccome no!
Sicuramente!
Se, mettiamo caso, siete alle prime armi,
ci sono un sacco di giovani qui,
scusate perché qua voi non vedete niente.
Ecco includiamo tutti.
Se siete alle prime armi
e non sapete proprio
che tipo di risata utilizzare,
optate per una risata qualunquista.
(Risata qualunquista)
Questa, signore, è come il nero,
va bene su tutto.
Ma come monito principale,
ascoltatelo.
Difficile crederlo, ma l’uomo
ha molto nella sua testa.
(Risate)
C’è niente da ridere, veramente,
gli uomini sono pieni di cose in testa.
Lasciate che le esprima:
(silenzio)
Passato questo minuto, dritte...
(Applausi)
Dai, un po’ più di energia
in questo applauso!
(Applausi)
Passato questo minuto,
dritte al punto numero quattro:
mettetevi nei suoi panni.
Pensate allo stress
che ha dovuto subire al lavoro
e cercate di accoglierlo in una casa
che sia serena, pulita,
ma soprattutto silenziosa!
Al suo arrivo spegnete tutto:
asciugatrice, lavatrice,
frullatore, vibratore,
il tuo rancore.
Pensa a tutto il rumore
che ha dovuto sopportare.
Anche tu al minimo i commenti,
le considerazioni, i pensieri.
Vi stupireste di scoprire
quante inutili parole
possano essere sostituite
da eloquenti espressioni facciali.
Quindi non parlategli!
Anche perché ricordate,
qualunque cosa sia successa a voi,
a lui è successo di peggio.
Quindi, niente musi lunghi,
né lamentele per mancanze,
se vi manca qualcosa,
la colpa è soltanto la vostra.
Perché la regola fondamentale
per la perfetta moglie,
saltiamo tutte le altre,
andiamo direttamente alla numero dieci,
la più importante,
quella che raccoglie tutte le altre è
farsi vedere felici.
Siete sposate, ma che cosa volete
di più dalla vita?
Regalategli dei grandi sorrisi,
alternati a dei sospiri di sollievo
che esprimano il vostro stato di estasi
per il solo fatto di essere sposate
proprio con lui!
E se per caso non ci riuscite
perché quel giorno, che so, vi sentite
tristi o sole,
incomprese oppure frustrate, irrealizzate,
oppure, non so, totalmente prive
di stimoli e di obiettivi
o vorreste solamente scappare di casa
ma dove vai, che non hai manco
un conto in banca a nome tuo,
un banco posta, una raccolta punti,
un maialino di porcellana.
Allora cominci a vagare per casa
col mocio, così non sprechi tempo
e ripensi a quando da piccola
volevi fare l’avvocato
E ti sei sposata invece.
Hai fatto non uno, non due, tre figli,
perché è così che si fa,
è questo che fa una donna.
Ma la verità è che a te non bastava
essere solo una mamma.
Ma Dio ce ne guardi a dire
una cosa del genere a voce alta,
perché vuol dire essere una donna egoista
e allora, senza farlo pesare a nessuno,
hai comunque deciso di laurearti,
ci hai provato, lo volevi proprio
realizzare questo sogno
lo volevi davvero,
volevi una cosa che fosse solo tua.
Solo tua.
Volevi dimostrare
che si può fare, si può fare.
Si può essere una buona madre
e una donna realizzata nel lavoro
il tutto sempre con lo smalto alle unghie
e la piega fatta perché non pensino
che tu sia sciatta e, quindi, inaffidabile
e ti sei fatta un mazzo così
per dimostrarlo
ma chissà perché, chissà perché,
tu lo sai perché? Io non lo so perché.
Chissà perché, nonostante tutto,
al bivio tra la tua carriera e la famiglia
hai dovuto scegliere la famiglia.
Perché tuo marito guadagna di più,
il suo lavoro è più importante
e poi in fondo è colpa tua se non puoi
partorire e contemporaneamente lavorare
perché sei tu che devi
portarlo in grembo nove mesi,
più l’allattamento al seno,
che è più indicato,
più il tempo minimo da passare con lui
per non essere considerata
una cattiva mamma.
E adesso che hai adempiuto
al tuo dovere biologico
e puoi essere considerata
una donna a tutti gli effetti
senza sentirti in colpa,
adesso tu vorresti disperatamente
tornare al tuo lavoro, ma...
Ops!
Improvvisamente non sei più produttiva
e il tuo posto è stato dato
a un uomo giovane, ben piazzato,
altezza minima 1,80 m,
con la metà della tua esperienza,
ma senza figli e senza un utero,
così non c’è il rischio che possa farli.
E allora ti rassegni a fare la moglie
e la mamma perché diciamolo,
diciamolo tutte insieme, signore mie,
ma che cosa c’è di più bello
del focolare domestico?
Ma poi ti saresti pentita molto di più
se non avessi fatto i figli.
Si può avere la certezza di questo?
Potrei avere un documento,
un attestato, un passo della Bibbia
che mi dice che ho fatto la scelta giusta
perché io adesso non son proprio sicura.
Certo che sì! Ma sì, ma come no!
Ma che cosa c’è di più bello
di quando rientri la sera a casa
dopo aver portato i bimbi a scuola,
fatto i panni, la spesa,
dato da mangiare
al cane, al gatto, al pesce rosso,
risolto il problema della pace del mondo,
risolto il problema dei calzini spaiati,
fatto da mangiare tre primi diversi
perché quello mangia quello,
quello è intollerante,
quello celiaco, quell’altro è stronzo
e tuo marito rientra a casa stanco morto
perché ha lavorato tanto...
lui!
E si lamenta perché non voleva la pasta
al sugo che lo appesantisce la sera
voleva la minestrina col riso
come gliela faceva mamma.
Allora tu vorresti prendere solo
il posacenere di cristallo
che ti ha regalato sua madre
che tu non hai mai fumato in vita tua
e piantarglielo dritto in mezzo
alle palle degli occhi
e vedere il sangue che gli sgorga
dalle orecchie mentre grida pietà,
e gridargli:
Io mi sono rotta i coglioni!
(Applausi, urla e acclamazioni)
Ah allora se dovesse essere...
non è finito.
(Risate)
No perché qui, il maschio subito
che cerca... no non è finito!
Presentatore: Sapevo
che finiva così, vai, vai!
Ci hai provato, ci ha provato!
(Ride)
Vi dicevo, signore, se dovesse essere
uno di questi giorni qua,
voi fate un bel respiro
e sorridete lo stesso.
Lui
non noterà nulla di diverso in voi
e abbiate fiducia,
siamo solo nel 1957.
Abbiamo un futuro davanti radioso
e pieno di opportunità per noi.
(Risate)
Ed ecco che si conclude adesso
questo corso intensivo.
Musica!
(Applausi)
Grazie per avermi seguito,
spero che anche voi [possiate] diventare
delle mogli perfette
e se volete darmi retta,
Non vi sposate!
Non lo fate!
È un errore tremendo!
Non va più nemmeno di moda!